so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about Scott Snyder's witches
and what I'm hoping is that at the end
of this video you'll find the story
interesting enough to read as well as
have an understanding of the overall
themes that Scott Snyder was shooting
for with its creation
so witches was first released in October
of 2014 was written by Scott Snyder
drawn by March Simpson and published
under Image Comics however as we get
into this I want to provide some
backstory in Image Comics why it was
founded and wide enabled Snyder to write
The Witches story if you recall my video
on spawn we had talked about how Image
Comics was founded in 1992 by some of
Marvel and DC's top writers and artists
at the time including Todd McFarlane Jim
Lee Marc Silvestri and Rob Liefeld the
reason for this was due to the aftermath
of Steve Gerber's lawsuit against Marvel
regarding Howard the Duck and the
introduction of something called the
creator's Bill of Rights jumping back to
1981 after Steve Gerber created Howard
which went on to gain a cult following
of sorts Steve was fired for what was
believed to be his inability to meet
deadlines
however because his termination
coincided with Marvel's desire to branch
out into the film industry and effort to
hedge their bets against the comic books
speculation bubble when the intention
was announced to have Howard star in a
film there were filed a lawsuit on the
grounds of copyright infringement
alleging that he had created Howard and
by extension owned the rights to his
character on the other hand Marvel
argued that because Gerber had been
contracted and worked for Marvel any
characters he created with her exclusive
property and that Gerber had no rights
to it as a result and while he would go
on to lose the lawsuit Gerber's case was
landmark and that it brought together a
number of writers and artists at the
time who rallied around his case and
develops the Craters vez tablished that
any characters created by writers or
artists remade their exclusive property
allowing them to decide the direction
and manner in which they're licensed and
developed now while the bill was
designed to ensure that creators weren't
taken advantage of by larger publishing
companies and truth the Bill of Rights
had almost no impact on the industry and
has largely been ignored remaining
something of an archaic series of
guidelines that no longer remains of
concern to this end the previous
relationship between creators and
publishers as it existed prior to
Gerber's lawsuit remain the status quo
for around the next ten years or so
however during this time resentment was
continuing to brew among various writers
and artists who came to the belief that
they were being viewed as something to
be used by publishers rather than the
basis for their success because creators
like Todd McFarlane Jim Lee and Rob
Liefeld had found their success and
writing in
developing stories that receive critical
acclaim they were able to use this
popularity to organize a push to branch
away from the bigger publishers and
quite literally want to create our own
publishing company that would allow
writers and artists to develop their own
creations without the limitations of
sales and standards set upon them by the
bigger companies having said that during
a 2014 interview with comic vine the
Scott Snyder had stated that he and Mark
Simpson had been developing witches for
several years and that his purpose was
to analyze horror both within the comics
and other forms of media and provide a
story that returned horror back to its
roots to sidetrack for a second
historically there is a direct
correlation between what scares people
and the advancement of knowledge and
technology traditionally horror stories
that is to say stories which invoke fear
by way of religion ghostly apparitions
or the unknown date back as early as the
14th century with Dante Alighieri Divine
Comedy
prior to this or was a byproduct of
attempts to explain things that couldn't
be understood by society at the time
with Homer's epic poem Odyssey for
example the beings of Scylla and
Chartists served as an idiom of sorts
representing the choice between two
evils and that Chartists was a whirlpool
and Scylla was a series of sharp rocks
on a mountainside both of which resided
in a body of water called the strait of
messina
however because Greeks at the time were
primitive relative to today's standards
and because travelers rarely survived
their journey through the straight truth
gave way to legend and myth leading to
the Greeks developing stories to explain
why they couldn't understand meaning
that these natural phenomena became
monsters of the sea who consumed
travelers coming too close to them
however during the 14th century
Catholicism was the dominant religion
throughout Europe during which time the
churches use fear as a means to maintain
their authority at this point in history
the works of Italian poet Dante
Alighieri in his Divine Comedy Dutch
artist hai erroneous Bosh at his period
pieces as well as others serve to
provide depictions of hell and purgatory
establishing a view of what awaited the
various members of society should they
fail to follow the Church's teachings
nevertheless the earliest known works
involving horror after the fear of
Heaven and Hell came with Horace
Walpole's 1764 novel titled the castle
of a Toronto which focused more on the
horrors of humanity rather than
fictional beings but because this was
considered the first gothic novel
transitioning away from religious themes
set the stage for Bram Stoker's Dracula
Edgar Allen Poe's the Raven and HP
Lovecraft's Call of Cthulhu however as
technology and knowledge advanced
allowing for reasoned and peer
reviewable explanations of the
supernatural society found fewer and
fewer things to be afraid of meaning
that the horror genre stopped being an
issue of fear and was transformed into a
desire to pursue excitement and so with
witches it's not a look to issue number
one to set the stage for the rest of the
series use the overarching story as a
way to invoke the primal fear of
humanity regarding the unknown and
combine it with elements of classical
supernatural themes to create a story
that quite literally fed on the fear of
its reader to this end the first issue
of witches opens up in the woods of an
unnamed town using the art to indicate
that the comic is meant to provide us
with a different view of the traditional
idea of what witches are the scene
reveals a person trapped inside of a
tree calling for help the scene is met
with the arrival of a young boy named
him revealing that this woman is the
mother of Tim his curiosity as to why
she's inside of a tree is met by her
fear of whatever's chasing her and the
presumption that it intends to kill her
now where we would expect him to come to
her aid when he's instructed to use a
large rock to smash open the hole
allowing her to escape and Sten he hits
her across the face with it and so with
the mothers stunned by his actions and
seeming to be incapacitated him makes
the statement that pledged is pledged
with his mother being seized from behind
by hands belonging to an unknown figure
now to be honest what I love most about
this is just how dark and terrifying
everything is when I first gone through
this story the idea of a person being
trapped in a tree invoked a kind of
uncomfortable feeling and then I
couldn't help but have a few hairs lift
up on my back but having said that where
all of this is established to have taken
place in 1919 with this woman being a
member of the Kray family the story
shifts its focus to 2014 with the
introduction of the rooks family now at
the outset for me the comic feels a
little bit like a movie and that the
college starring character sailor Brooks
and her father are engaging in a bit of
back-and-forth banter involving
hippogriffs and truth the importance of
this is not for the introduction of the
witches into the story so much as to
provide us with a relationship between
sale and her father like many
traditional films and stories including
Amityville Horror and
shining this segment is meant to develop
the characters by having Charles do the
best he can to relate to his daughter
while sail tries to find a way to relate
to her father and so other conversation
involving the concept of placing
explosives in the anuses of hippogriffs
and blowing them up we learn that this
discussion served as a means for sale to
cope with the idea of starting at a new
school and Charles helping her with the
process however at the same time we also
learned that an event seems to have
taken place in the history of the family
although we don't really know what it is
in addition to this the particular event
appears to have transcended into
something of legend or pop culture and
that rather than being able to start her
time in school fresh without any track
record the event will likely influence
the various students opinions of her and
so with the bus arriving the advisor
father offers is that if the situation
in school becomes too much to bear
regard to the various kids giving her a
hard time or the stress is too much to
cope with he can bring her home until
she calms down and is ready to go back
again for here we follow sail during her
trip to school where slender begins the
process of providing some backstory on
her character now what's really cool
about this is that the back story as he
provides it has a very similar feel to
his time on the Batman series what I
mean here is that with court of owls
death of the family and end game Snyder
took the road of a slow burn meaning
that the entire line of stories served
to build up to Bruce's confrontation
with the Joker but along the way various
characters were introduced who would
play some kind of a role later on indeed
where we see an unknown man roaming
through the woods asking about a pledge
with Snyder providing no information on
who he is the story follows the same
format as Snyder's Batman and that
things transition to sailor while she's
in science class learning about the
principles of a chemical versus physical
changes on the atomic structure as it
relates to fireworks during this time
sailor meets a fellow classmate who
informs her that their science teacher
is actually what they refer to as a dick
crusher and that whenever he's walking
around the class he inevitably brushes
his penis up against the girls through
his pants
now again where this portion of the
discussion isn't important what is
important is when the classmate asks
sailor about one of the story of her
killing a girl is true now the reason
why this is important is because it's at
this point the story moves away from
focusing on a more mysterious feeling -
emphasizing suspense and horror but the
issue with this segment is that it
actually
acquires us to read a little bit between
the lines what we're told is that sailor
is meeting with a girl named Annie and
then at some point sailor had made a
comment about how bullies suck now the
initial indication here is that there's
some kind of backstory behind the two
and that maybe they had fought or that
some kind of beef existed but the basis
of the feud is actually revealed to be
due to the fact that any simply hates
sailor because she's gay now we could
probably take this to be an instance of
Snyder making a reference to the issues
faced by homosexuals regarding the
various forms of prejudice but in truth
Snyder as far as I know has never really
taken that kind of stance with his
stories proving this to be true within
the context of the story
sailor lashes out at Annie by drawing a
knife and frustration of constantly
being picked on in addition to this wear
sailor intends to take a revenge by
presumably killing Annie it's revealed
that Annie had actually brought a gun to
their meeting at this point Snyder
throws all pretense out the window by
having any instructs Aylor to use the
handle of the knife and masturbate with
it now this particular portion of the
story is actually pretty extreme and in
truth it's meant to be the reason why is
because again witches is designed to
invoke a series of emotions in the
extreme degree not in the sense that
were to feel disgusted by what it is
that we're reading but in the sense that
this is all designed to prepare us for
what's to come next what I mean here is
that while sailor begins to undress
herself the two were met with a series
of strange sounds in the background
where Annie operates under the
assumption that either someone had
followed them or sailor herself had
informed her parents of what was
happening her reaction is to state that
she's willing to kill sailor and her
family if this was the case however when
sailor denies this to be true and he
goes to investigate at which point she's
physically seized by a series of hands
belonging to individuals that we can't
see
following this were any plates for help
from sailor her fear of the situation
combined with how fast everything
happens Leafs are virtually helpless
with Annie being pulled into the tree
itself leaving nothing but a hole in
blood at this point we jump to the
evening with sailor preparing to go to
bed but having a conversation with her
father now something that's cool about
this is that despite trying to create a
story that throws back to the roots of
classical horror Snyder doesn't forget
the small things the conversation as is
taking place between sailor and her
father establishes that despite her
experience sailor maintained
relationship with their parents and that
they function in a support capacity but
at the same time Snyder also leaves
things a little ambiguous what I mean
here is that with her flashback we're
aware of what happened to Annie and that
she was taken by supernatural forces
but when Saylor discusses this with her
father she simply talked about Annie's
disappearance
what Snyder seems to be doing here is
leaving it to us to decide at the moment
about whether or not Saylor's parents
are aware of what happened or if their
only information is that she simply
vanished in addition to this Saylor asks
the question of whether or not she was
the one responsible for Annie's
vanishing which provides some valuable
insight into her character and the
Sailor doesn't fully understand what
happened suffers from survivor's guilt
and may even be attending to believe
that what she saw wasn't what actually
happened and so following Charles
downstairs as he speaks with his wife we
learned the following the incident with
Annie the family had moved for the
purpose of attempting to get away from
everything that had happened where they
knew that the situation was inescapable
in the sense that Saylor would have the
events ingrained in her mind the hope of
her parents was that if given some
distance Saylor could begin the healing
process and start over and so is this
first issue begins to come to a close we
pick up with Saylor in her room during
which time a hissing sound is heard from
a tree outside calling out to it and
attending to figure out what she's
hearing the sound is revealed to be
coming from Annie who seems to have
either reanimated or returned despite
having been killed
now the indication here as it's shown is
that once a person is killed by one of
the witches they seem to become one of
them doesn't to exist within the trees
and continue the process of killing
those who stray too close or are
sacrificed and so is Saylor crying out
in terror her father rushes upstairs
while the unknown man from earlier in
the story sits outside of the house
coughing his teeth up with that being
said we're gonna bring this video to an
end and let me know what you guys think
about this story so far down in the
comment section and that will catch you
guys under preusse